to whom it may concern' resume is  something for appeal myself let's have a  appeal time my big reason of come to  Canada Europe North and South America  travel so I apply to your shop I am NOT  a good English user but when I was in  Korea everyone called me ace you are the  best at Factory Hotel farm restaurant  Mart especially I love always smile  working environment to short time I  worked custom service but it is best  work in my life and I want to feel again  by the way I worked server and kitchen  help in the Canada  I am always good one I am working please  feel me I have brave fight two wild bear  I have strong arm to lift wild bear  I am so fast more than the train I can  work without pay right now  I do not care when will you pay me  please pay me after you think I have  qualifications for get a pay sincerely  thank you for your time and  consideration  you